hey y'all it's andrew catch here and in
this tight tuesday video we're going to
be building upon
my previous week's video on
classification models
uh and we're going to be focusing now on
regression models
which is basically the part two however
regression models are actually pretty
simple
uh especially with their metrics i'm
also going to make this video focusing
on the tuning
of our pre-processing hyper parameters
which is pretty cool because what's
really good about the tidy models
package is not only do they have a great
package for tuning hyper parameters for
models
we're also able to tune our recipes
which can really add a lot of predictive
power to our models
so i'm going to open up rstudio i'm
going to
bring in our markdown file i'm going to
call this tidy
tuesday regression pre-processing
okay uh i'm going to
clear the garbage out i'm gonna load in
the tidy verse
uh tidy models and also
uh the ames housing data set
which is i think a great toy data set
for understanding
uh regression metrics i'm going to do
the make aims function which is from the
aims housing data set
um library which will basically create
our data set for our regression model
so what's cool about the make aims is
it's essentially like a
the iris of regression so if we do our
summary
um we'll see that all the all these
features or all these columns
are basically cleaned for us or not
missing any data
um it's the correct forms such as like
factors
and numerical data and we have a nice
little sale price right there
okay so what we're gonna do now is just
create
our seed so we're going to say set dot
seed is let's see here 31
i'll do a tidy split
create a 80 20 split with the data given
our df so
drop equals 0.8 we do not have to
stratify
we could stratify based on a specific um
categorical variable however i'm just
going to leave it
open um and then i'm going to create my
trained data
so training teddy split
our test data so testing
tidy split and then we're going to
create our k
folds uh data which will be v
fold c v train
data execute this code chunk and now we
have our train and test sets
or our actual model so the main gist of
this
uh video is going to be actually tuning
uh the pre-processing or the recipes
so we're gonna initialize a recipe uh
our formula will be
sales price using all our features and
we're going to give it our train data
okay we're going to pipe in first uh
what i like to do is actually add in
basically the the pre-processing that
will remove the features so
one thing that people do when creating
regression models
is to remove all the correlated
variables
so when you remove the correlated
variables generally um
you want to do this with like linear
models because it assumes that these
variables aren't correlated
and it has to deal with a lot of
assumptions so when you do step
correlation
the default threshold is 0.9 so if these
two numerical values
have a correlation uh value of over 0.9
it will remove one of the features but
if you think about it
correlation is a pretty arbitrary um
threshold right so why do we why do we
decide that 0.9 will be our threshold
well because generally it's just good
practice to do 0.9 but what if we what
if 0.8 will give us more
uh more value or what a 0.7 will give us
more value
so that's something where we could
actually start tuning this
uh pre-processing feature
so we're gonna say all numeric valuables
uh values we're gonna
apply this correlation uh filtering
process
however we're also gonna prevent it from
applying to the outcomes
then what we're going to do is going to
say threshold
is equal to tune so it's just like
tuning our actual machine learning
models we're just going to give it a
tuning
parameter okay so we're also going to do
step near zero variance
in this case i think that frequency
cutoff is pretty straightforward so i'm
just going to leave it as is
i'm going to do minus all outcomes
and then i'm going to do a step
normalize all numeric
minus all outcomes step
yo johnson the reason why i use eo
johnson over say
uh box cox is i see that we have some
negative values
uh specifically in the longitude so i
fear that's the right way to do it
oops minus all
outcomes okay and then
what i also am going to do is i'm going
to do step pca
we're also going to do a principal
component analysis and with principle
components analysis
uh they're going to make a certain
amount of principal components
and one thing that they're going to say
is well how many pca components we want
right so if we do num
comp um we can choose how many
components
generally the first component will have
the most amount of variants explained
however we can start adding more
uh and with like carrot they would just
give you the 100 uh
principal components which isn't really
great because there's some diminishing
returns with the number of components
so i think this is a great thing to tune
okay then what we're going to do is
we're going to do a step other
uh we're going to do that to all of the
nominal variables or the categorical
variables
and again with step nominal of step
other it also has
a threshold and this threshold will say
like okay if
like if the bottom 20 percent of our
data
our category features we'll just convert
that to other
or if it's not shown up a lot uh we'll
convert it to other
which is another thing that we could
tune okay
and then what we're going to do is also
step dummy and all
nominal so one problem with this
is that we have thresholds right here
so step other has a threshold and then
step uh correlation has a threshold
and their their tuning parameters are
the same
and that can run into errors when we're
trying to give it different values
because ideally
we would think that hey maybe our
correlated values
will have a different threshold than our
step other or a lumping feature
one thing we can do is we can just add
in inside the tune function
a name for it so what i'm going to call
this is num
thresh and for this for step other i'll
say cat
thresh and if you think about it we can
also do
correlations or different type of
correlation thresholds for different
variables so instead of saying all
numeric would say
oh well we want to do these correlated
variables with
say things that have to do with price
and then our other correlations will
have a different correlation
score or threshold for other numerical
variables so this type of tuning thing
or tuning name and convention can really
help uh
basically uh preventing any confusion uh
with our training parameters
what i'm going to call this is i'm going
to call it a tidy wreck
i'm going to say define a
pre-processing method where
we will tune correlation
threshold number of component of
pca components and
a lumping
threshold okay which is a pretty useful
thing that we could do
for a linear model okay
now i'm going to say create a
or i'm going to say define our model a
model
in this case i'm actually just going to
make one model and this will be a simple
linear regression model
in fact actually it'll be a a lasso
model
the linear reg penalty
is tuned so how many features we want to
remove will be dependent on
the penalty score and their mixture will
be one
that may that way we can actually shrink
the values to zero
if we need to we're going to set the
mode to regression
that set the engine oops sets
engine to glm net
and then our model metrics which will be
our classification our
regression metrics which we metric set
and for me i think the default metric
that you should always understand
is rmse or root mean squared error
r squared r squared traditional
and then mean absolute error
right so this is an already pretty
pretty straightforward thing we define
our model
we defined the metrics we wanted to set
that's the same thing as like
classification model
but now we're going to do the actual
tuning parameters that we wanted to find
so
uh create a tuning
grid for a model and
pre-processing methods
first let's make our model grid because
we know how to do it
grid regular so we're just going to make
a regular grid
parameters give it our linear model
and we're going to give the levels of
five
so if we look at our model grid we have
our penalty scores
that are five different scores
which i think is a pretty fine amount to
do for a penalty
great now let's actually do our
pre-processing grip
grid pre-processing grid which i'll say
rec grid
we're going to do the same thing greg
regular parameters
in this case we're going to give it our
tidy rec and our levels will be five
if we actually just show our parameters
and say tidy rec
we can see we have our num thresh which
is our our correlation threshold
our number of components and then our
categorical threshold
so that's pretty good that's pretty
straightforward uh and we'll do that
uh one thing that we should see is
if we look at our uh our our values
some of these values don't make a lot of
sense for example
num threshold and cat threshold some of
these are zeros
and in our pre-processing method
we don't want a threshold of zero
because special zero basically converts
everything
into other or just removes everything so
for example with a correlation threshold
it would essentially say that we would
not want
a any values any columns that had a had
a
correlation score above zero which is
unrealistic
the categorical threshold is saying that
any score
that was zero uh was above zero percent
would be
then transferred over to other so these
values do not make a lot of sense for
all we want
luckily uh the dials package has a
filter
so we can say is num thresh we'll just
say it's greater than 0.7
and cat brush so if we look at our
what's your what's our uh
step other so
threshold oops i want to look at the
what's the default threshold for the
step other
so it's 0.05 so we're going to say cat
thrash is going to be less than
0.1 uh oopsie crap
cat thrash must be sizing one
cat numb thrash uh
cat thrash
what is the cat cat thrash
numb thrush oh and i'll say
and there you go so now we did that
we we gave it a threshold um
oh i'm gonna say it's a greater than a
point sorry about that so now what we
can see here is that
our numerical thresholds are above 0.7
and our categorical threshold is above
0.01
so that way we can basically kind of
fine-tune these thresholds
to meet what is our realistic values
for our pre-processing methods and
lastly
uh dials has our dials has this thing
where we can do merge
so we can merge model grid and rec grid
and we combine them together so now we
have all these tuning parameters we've
combined our model parameters
with our pre-process pre-processing
parameters so i'm going to say
model rec grid i'm going to say
this is combine the model and
pre-processing parameters
into a single grid great
so we have that now what we can do is
finally tune the
tune the lasso model
so model res tune grid
we're going to pass on our linear model
our preprocessor will be our tidy wreck
our resamples will be our k
folds data our grid
is equal to our model rec grid
and our metrics will be defined as our
model
metrics
so we're going to run this and this is
going to start tuning
um if you notice on let's see here if
you notice right here
we may run into some errors but let's
just say that we
had no values and that's fine because it
basically tuned it where
uh they ran it errors however with many
folds it'll basically have enough
samples uh that actually succeeded
and didn't remove completely everything
uh hopefully we won't run into this
error
uh for this session just because we
added these filters but if you don't add
this type of filter you'll get that
error
so we're gonna let this run for a little
bit and uh now i'm just gonna kind of go
over
the uh uh was it the
the regression metrics and kind of
explain what you should be looking for
for your regression metrics and why
regression metrics
in my opinion are a little bit simpler
to understand
so just intuitively regression metrics
we're trying to predict just a number
and we already have a number we want so
one of the biggest things is just the
difference
um and that's what basically regression
metrics are trying to measure just the
overall difference between
our predicted score and our actual score
it's more straightforward than like say
binary classes
however there are some conventional ways
to go into it
for example root mean squared error is a
very popular metric
where it takes uh the errors so the
difference between the two the predicted
and actual
squares it sums it up and then takes the
square root of it
and this basically will penalize a more
uh basic it'll basically penalize uh
model predictions that are very far off
which is a little bit it's good in my
opinion it's probably the thing that we
should be tuning
off of however when you're actually
communicating so if you actually build a
cool pricing model
and you want to communicate it to
stakeholders mean absolute error is the
best
i think mean absolute air is the best
metric in presentations because mean
absolute air just takes the absolute
error
for each sample and it takes the average
of it so really what you can say is
on average our model is off by this much
uh this many
points right very straightforward
everyone will understand it
it's very hard to think in root mean
squared errors because that just sounds
very complicated to stakeholders
and it's e it's the best way to do the
best way to communicate data science
is simple in layman's terms so that's
why i mean absolute error is the best
additionally i'm sure if you do a lot of
linear modeling you think of like r
squared and r squared traditional
i personally am not a fan of r squared
and r squared traditional
because r squared has a lot of
connotations for other things
so for example you probably have thought
of r squared adjusted r squared
etcetera and our the problem with r
squared
with predictive modeling is it doesn't
really compare the actual predictions
additionally when you increase the
amount of features your r squared
will intrinsically go up so it's
somewhat of a flawed
variable which is why they have adjusted
r squared um i personally i think r
squared is a fine thing to share in
research and among other data scientists
and analysts and statisticians
or r squared is not a good metric for
communication especially in the business
applications
that's just my own perspective of it but
i think uh it's something that people
should be aware about
so this is still running um i'm probably
gonna
either cut the video and resume it or
i'm just going to wait it out for a few
more minutes
okay so the model res finished tuning so
let's actually look at it
um i'm going to pull the dot notes just
to see if there's any error
and there are no errors from the tuning
process so that kind of means that
our added filters um did what we wanted
to do
so we didn't have any um we didn't
filter out our all our data completely
so what i'm going to do is to collect
metrics
and what we can see here is our our
features
so we can say like uh was it
um we can kind of uh group
by dot metric
and then arrange mean
so which so this this was the one that
had the highest r squared
uh we can kind of filter out we can see
again this one had the highest r squared
so uh one one little thing that we can
see here uh
i we'll say descending
okay so we can see that uh you know
using a threshold of 0.75
a correlation without 0.75 using one
principle component
and a categorical threshold of 0.1
we have a higher higher we have a
higher our mean squared error let's see
what what's on the bottom
first
actually you know i'm going to do group
by and then i'll do a summarize
um min equals min
mean median equals median
uh mean and then mean equals mean
mean max equals max mean
so now we have some more summarized
metrics
okay so our mean absolute error our mean
absolute error is this
which is very good all right mean here
this is a very good score
um we see our r square is in the 80
percent
tile range and then we consider r
squared traditionals in the 79 82 etc
in this case i'm going to focus mostly
on main absolute error
okay so let's actually view this um for
each fold
okay so collect metrics
summarize equals oops summarize
equals false
and then what i'm going to do is uh
pivot
longer num rush
to cat brush
i'm going to filter dot metric is equal
to mae
and then i'm going to gg plot it out and
say x equals value
y equals dot estimate
gm
smooth plus facet
wrap and i'm going to do it by each
uh tuning process for the principle
for the pre-processing so when
evaluating this we can see that as we
increase our categorical threshold or we
let in
more of our categorical variables
we can see our uh mean absolute error
uh d uh increases so as we increase our
threshold
our uh our it increases we see our
number of components basically is
staying the same
and we can see how our numerical
threshold as we increase it
uh starts to uh
um starts to decrease so that's kind of
interesting we can see that higher
quality variables the more choroidal
variable
uh is the more likely we remove it the
better our model
for our categorical threshold we're
actually more comfortable with allowing
more of our calorical features
so that's pretty interesting okay so i'm
going to
do model res and i'm going to select
best by one standard error and i'll say
mae
and we can see this is our final thing
so what we can see is our model would
like a decent amount of categorical
variables we only want one component
and we can basically leave our
correlation features
basically standard okay
so i'm going to switch this to select
s and say emmy and i'll say uh
model tune
and i'll do finalize
model linear model and model
tune right so we have that and then i'll
find it
if i don't give it to our linear uh
what's
our linear model
so let's say uh select
uh parameters with the
metrics and then say
apply parameters
to the model and finally what we're
going to do is a last fit
so what i'm going to do is create a
workflow so let's say
i'll crawl is the pricing model i'll
give it a workflow
add the model which is our linear model
add our recipe which is our tidy
rack and then i'll say
uh pricing model fit
class fit pricing model
oops pricing model and then our tidy
split oh prep arguments turn into
do you want to use
oh that's why i have to do the finalized
recipe so i'll do finalize
recipe so tidy wreck and then i'll do
the model
tune so let's say
tidy wreck
we have those
and then we'll we'll do the final fit i
write that
okay so now we can do is our collect
predictions
so we have our prediction and our sale
price and finally we can do our
you know ma i think we can do the mae
function
or what we can yeah we can do the mae
which is
it dot pred and
which is 19 30 19.
we can look at our our actual thing
which is right here
which does a little bit better which is
pretty good so
our final monofit looks a little bit
better than our our
in sample um k fold set
what we can also do is finally kind of
like view our
model predictions i'm going to say is
finalize model workflow
[Music]
train model on
train set and evaluate on test set
and say calculate test sets
uh mau so if we look at our pricing
model fit
select predictions
and we can just gg bot it out so gg
what a yes x equals dot prod y equals
sale price gm
line plus gm smooth
we can see oops gm
point we can see that our model follows
it pretty well
we can also add a geom a b
line slope equals one
intercept zero
and we can basically see how yeah
sometimes our model
is under pricing our our house assets
however a lot of these things that
are under pricing like say this one is
kind of an outlier for a linear model
and overall this is just a linear model
so this
uh this model is doing very well for
pricing these ames houses
and what we can really do is extend this
linear model
that we basically tuned all the
parameters on to our
our more complex black box models so one
another
strategy i think is a good idea is just
always think about
linear models at basically free
computing power
so if you want to do a lot of tuning
parameters if you want to select
uh features from a wide data set using a
linear model and basically
pre-processing it and letting the linear
model do the work to
basically select the things you want
programmatically and statistically
is a good option to basically doing some
some like um
some pretty simple feature selection in
future engineering
so i know this video is pretty fast but
i think regression models are pretty
straightforward especially
especially with the metrics but i do
think that tuning
model pre-processing is a very powerful
thing that in the tightest models
universe
and it's honestly under-documented and
under-reported in the tidy models
framework
so i hope you guys enjoyed this video
i'll see you guys next week and tidy on